[Music]
what's shiny liquid conducts electricity
and is also the surname of a legendary
rock star yeah you guessed it mercury
this naturally occurring element has a
lot of uses but it's also quite
dangerous even a tiny amount can be
poisonous so what if we had oceans of it
could Earth Harbor oceans of liquid
mercury what effect would it have on the
planet and what effect would it have on
humanity this is what if and here's what
would happen if oceans were liquid
mercury before we go diving into a pool
full of mercury we better learn about
its properties mercury is the only metal
that exists as a liquid at room
temperature both water and mercury turn
into gas or vapour at higher
temperatures yet as a basic element
mercury doesn't break down like water it
merely changes state this makes it toxic
to ingest and especially volatile as it
often ends up accumulating in our soil
oceans and in
many sea creatures we like to eat a lot
of this is as a result of human-made
mercury emissions from the burning of
fossil fuels gold mining or the mineral
extraction of cinnabar mercury works
especially well as an amalgam or metal
alloy making it great for extracting
gold from rocks forming tooth fillings
with silver ore extending battery life
by bonding with zinc it also expands and
contracts with changes in temperature
making mercury a key ingredient in
thermometers although it's incredibly
useful
what would a whole ocean of mercury do
to our planet well perhaps the most
immediate change we can notice is a
whole lot of objects floating up to the
surface which may be great for treasure
hunters or cryptozoologists Hey look is
that Nessie over there oh wait nevermind
just another log literally anything
sunken throughout history would come
flying up to the surface making the
ocean a massive floating dump this is
because mercury is 13 and a half times
denser than water making it incredibly
buoyant
according to Archimedes principle the
upward buoyant force exerted on a body
immersed in fluid is equal to the weight
of the fluid that is displaced like salt
water mercury has a higher density than
freshwater so most objects will float to
the top but be unable to find
equilibrium even an anvil so brace
yourself
fearless sea travelers your boats are
going to lose balance and tip right over
and if you happen to fall into the ocean
you'd make a little splash and Bob
around like a human boy
in fact if you had a good set of
flippers or incredible balance you could
try to walk across the ocean but enough
of the antics we've got a looming
problem concerning the basic necessities
with no water left in the ocean we have
to produce it artificially in a lab and
we likely wouldn't have enough energy to
produce enough water for the entire
global population we might end up waging
war over the stuff and post-apocalyptic
desert battles ok that's if we managed
to endure any of the planetary effects
surprisingly changing our oceans to
mercury would only increase Earth's mass
by 0.26 percent thankfully this wouldn't
be enough to cause any drastic changes
to our orbit or gravity but the added
weight on the Earth's mantle would put a
lot more pressure on tectonic plates
this would trigger catastrophic
earthquakes and volcanoes all over the
world
killing billions if not every living
thing on earth sorry to burst your
mercury bubble even if he managed to
survive the atmosphere could kill you
clouds of mercury would form and the air
we breathe would contain poisonous
mercury vapor causing severe
neurological problems like anxiety
memory problems and tremors we'd have to
wear masks 24/7 and a whole lot of
sunscreen with its shiny metal surface
mercury has a higher albedo or
reflectivity than snow
meaning we'd have a lot more solar
radiation to contend with all this
increased radiation could lead to a
cooling effect significantly lowering
the overall global temperature of the
earth
I guess the silvery lining here is that
we might actually solve global warming
only briefly though humankind probably
wouldn't survive very long in the severe
toxicity of a liquid mercury planet but
back here in the real world maybe we
could at least learn practical ways of
staying afloat and surviving on a
sinking ship it's all here in our new
series how to survive
you